[موسيقى]
معلومات عن قصص وروايات تحوي تفاصيل عده
لتاريخ العلا ينقلها الروات من ابناء
العلا لنقل الاسرار وتاريخ وروايات
الحضارات منذ الاف السنين
[موسيقى]
مشاعر لما بنحكي احنا على روات يعني شو
بدك تقولي لنا بهذا الموضوع شو يعني رواه
وشو طبيعه عملهم احنا اسمنا
نروي القصه لكل واحد وطريقته بحيث انه
زائر لما يجي هو هدفه
والاهم انه يكون يستفيد غالبيتنا معاهم
انجلش واكيد العربي لكن ما شاء الله انا
اكثرنا معاهم عده لغات مثل الاسباني
والفرنسيه والالماني
احد الجزائري مثلا
بطريقه بسيطه جدا بطريقه ممتعه ما يعني ما
تخرب جو انه انا جاي هنا اساسا
[موسيقى]
كونك انت راوي او مرشد هذا يعني انت سفير
البلدك
هذه المنطقه اللي احنا كبرنا فيها واللي
نتذكرها قبل ما يكون هذا كله احنا الان ما
شاء الله يعني نرويها
ونخبرها للناس المشاعل في عدد تقريبا لعدد
الرواد نقدر نقول احنا ما يقارب اكثر من
30 شخص متوزعه بين كل المواقع الاثريه
سواء هنا
كريمه وخيبر ومتوزعين بشكل
[موسيقى]
عالي على كل النهار
جيل بعد جيل سيروي الحكايه ويحفظ ارث
العلا الثقافي والتاريخي والحضاري عبر
مجموعات من الرواه تنقل الصوره بالكلمه
والشواهد جيل يسعى لجعل مدينته اقرب
للعالم ولجعل العالم اقرب الى العلا لصباح
العربيه نادين خماش العلا